very exciting for a young man making his
first start as a member of the braves
jock peterson tonight last seminar home
for freed excellent work four and two
only one home run a lot i really like
what peter moylan said about max
establish that fastball tom last three
starts five innings a lot of pitches
that's not been like max the last couple
of years in rotation no it hasn't and he
i agree with peter 100 he's got to pitch
off his fastball opponents have a 341
average on his 14 fastball this year
compared to 198 last year so that will
speak of command issues we'll look at
yandi diaz leading off as a bouncing
ball hit towards short dan's be
positioned perfectly
and a ground ball out gets the knight
started for max free if both these
starters are right you're going to see a
lot of ground ball outs
for the braves and fleming for tampa bay
so you hear the cheers for austin
meadows he had a big night last night
both the georgia kids
in tampa bay colors had a big night and
they just picked off franco
max free with that great pick off move
throws the rookie and there's out number
two 18 career pick-offs for max freed
and he was late and then slipped well
and that's how you know you have a good
pick-off move too because franco
obviously was going nowhere and the rule
of thumb is if you're not stealing you
should never get picked off and he still
got picked off as meadows hits with two
outs full count
hard hit ball but into the shift that'll
be easy max freed with his pick off move
the ninth turned in by the braves this
year helps him along and jack peterson
debuts as a starter at the plate next
left-hander josh fleming making his 15th
appearance seventh start of the year
covering 69 innings pitch so far 42
punch outs to only those 17 walks will
work quick and features a heavy sinker
that he throws about 45 percent of the
time and has a high ground ball right on
well here's peterson officially joined
the club last night making his first
start in an atlanta uniform
fly ball back into center field
phillips is there and he tracks it down
one away swanson
there's a swing in the line driving the
right field but directly at randy
rosarina who squares off and catches for
the second out of the unit here's
freddie freeman coming off a four hit
knife out of the pitch slice to center
but right at brett phillips he's coming
in again and three fly ball outs for
josh fleming and the braves go one two
three good start for max freed he has
faced the minimum in his first two
innings he'll have the bottom part of
the tampa bay order coming up in the
third inning fred phillips he balls two
strikes
breaking ball got him and strike three
called back-to-back strikeouts for max
free he's looking more like himself yeah
good good pitch there breaking ball that
was a little bit more of the slider
swept across the zone phillips gave up
on it caught the corner taylor walls
this one's hit hard but right into the
shift taking on the short hop by ozzy on
the left side of the infield he has
plenty of time to wing it over there to
freddie freeman and two down two up two
downs josh fleming's gonna step in the
batter's box for the first time and he
strikes him out three up three down max
freed has set down seven straight
six-game hitting streak for freeman well
let's see if the braves can convert that
into the game's first run ozzy albee's
bounced out his first time up as this
one is scorched towards center phillips
on the run still sprinting still going
still going he can't get it it's off the
base of the wall freddie on his way to
third he's rounding third he will score
ozzy's headed to third he'll flop in
with a triple in the braves lead mr
extra base head has another one and his
first of the night puts atlanta in front
of the fourth that's what makes ozzie so
dangerous that ball is not a strike that
ball is down out of the zone and he just
golfs that ball to dead center field
with carrie which is hard to do
and freddie got a great read on that he
was chugging the whole way so the braves
strike first here's austin reilly
infield in and he unloads to deep left
this one though playable for meadows he
back pedals makes the catch all these
tags and scored abc baseball and it's
two to nothing two nothing braves bottom
of the fourth inning runners at first
and second and two down for max free
braves runners lead the pitch and
freight shoots one down the left-field
line meadows long run can't get it
that's gonna score one here comes smith
the third they're gonna wave it relay
throw won't be made they walk smith to
pitch to freight and he doubles home two
more i told you it was a mistake yeah
cut her a little bit up served it in the
left field and meadows wasn't able to
cut it off which unable to smith to
score all the way from first now jack
peterson will try to chase him home
making his first start
he unloads that's headed for the braves
bullpen welcome to atlanta jack peterson
the graves have scored six runs in
back-to-back games after the all-star
break tom and we're only in the fourth
in game two tonight yeah look we talked
about in the open offense was great last
night and they've taken advantage of
opportunities again tonight and boy what
a way to break in for jog that's why
they got him
he's got some pop the man that started
this six-run rally last inning is the
man that starts the braves fifth two
balls in a strike for freddie freeman
nobody on or out
and he hits a high fly ball belted
toward the braves bullpen freeman goes
above the bullpen his fourth homer in
his last five games the braves add the
extra point it's seven to nothing max
free the battery he's had himself quite
a night he has single he has doubled he
has scored a run and he has driven in
two no balls in a strike
line drive it's a three-hit game for max
free he's making it look way too easy so
two singles a double a runs scored two
rbis and he's throwing a four hit
shutout and here's the scenario that
brian snicker envisioned multiple
runners on for guys like freeman and now
freddie launches one toward left that's
gonna be deep enough to bring home three
there's the catch max tags he'll jog
home and score without a throw freddie
freeman with another rbi two tonight 54
for the year 25th game for santana seven
out of his last eight and four in a row
have been scoreless he's throwing the
ball well one ball no strikes
ground ball to the right side into the
ship ozzie's got it and an easy little
throw to freddie freeman walls grounds
out one down here in the eighth inning
as this one knocks the glove off santana
he recovers and makes the play wow how
about that heads-up effort yeah kind of
hit him right in the thumb look like
knocked it off good presence of mind to
find the baseball take his time make a
good throw now yandy diaz the hitter
and this one up the middle dansby
swanson nice pick 360 and a bullet to
first atlanta is doing it all tonight
it's the middle of the eighth this will
be the seventh shutout for the braves
since june 20th if they can finish off
the rays right here two on two out and
tampa bay pitcher francisco mejia is
coming up lifted toward right how
apropos is this first start for jack
peterson he'll enjoy his first win as a
brave nine-nothing is your final score
the braves got six runs in the fourth
inning
max freight seven innings of shutout
ball he had three hits two rbis
[Applause]